Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast Dan. Huh?
Just checking in on you. I'm just
checking in on you. How are Ya?
How's it going? I'm actually doing great
despite the, uh, that cough I just did.
There wasn't a real cough. I
just, you know, I've, I've,
I've run out of unique ways to
say I'm just checking in on you.
I tried to do it a little bit
differently and I, I got nothing left.
I don't know what you want from
me. Um, anyway, so let's get on.
Let's get on with the podcast here.
You know, this is just a quick one.
This isn't even an official podcast,
despite the fact that I have
fucking advertising on it.
It's not an official one.
This is me just poking my head into a
little office into your little cubicle and
your living room. If you're unemployed or
maybe a, you're living off a trust. Yeah,
it's a great big shout out to anybody
just sitting around living off a trust.
You know,
what are you going to do today?
And I go down to the art store
and get yourself an Easel,
you know, little canvas,
Duck Payton. That's what people do. You
know, when you're like super fucking rich,
there's no reason for you to go outside.
There's no, there's no fucking reason. I,
I really can't stand when people judge,
you know,
trust fund babies.
I feel that's like one of the,
one of the biggest issues that this
country is dealing with right now.
We see harsh judgment of
trust fund babies, you know,
I mean,
anybody can be fucking broke.
It'd be like Lou that rich can't just
sitting over there doing nothing.
What a waste. What a waste of
a fucking life, you know? Well,
let me tell you this. She was subway
sandwich sheet and judgmental. Fuck.
Let me ask you this. If you were in
that situation, what would you be doing?
Because I can tell you what,
I will be doing the exact same fucking
thing and all you fucking people on your
high horse.
No. Do what I could do it. You know,
I one of those people, you know,
people know this.
People know me.
I have to wake up with a purpose.
If I don't have a purpose in life,
shut the fuck up your bills.
All right?
That's what you're doing and you're
walking out the door and you chasing the
fucking Keratin. Some someday you're
dreaming. You dream that that care,
it's not going to be there. You want
to be that diesel guy. You know?
Look at George Bush,
man.
Do you ever see a guy enjoying not
being president more than that guy?
He's actually good at what he does. He's
not a trust fund baby either, by the way.
I'm just saying,
you know he's actually good at it.
Just sits there.
I wonder what he thinks about it.
There's no way to be present
when you leave as president.
You have dead bodies on your conscience.
Whether you made the right
decision or the wrong decision.
At some point you had to shoot off
some missiles because who's kidding?
Who America is the world's babysitter.
Okay?
We know what we know what's best for you,
okay?
And what is best for you is to do what
we say and give us your natural resources
as we pretend to care about your people.
Okay?
It's like a lifetime movie.
Everybody's acting like
something special's happening
at the end of the day was
wasn't that really just a bunch of
shit so he could fucking make money?
Isn't that what it was?
I have no idea what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about trust fund babies
and I'm sick of the judgment of him.
Who judges a baby, first of
all, kind of a fucking person.
You maybe that's why God didn't give
you money. You have to think about that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's called Karma.
Isn't that the most
overused talking expression?
Karma isn't. My theory on Karma.
Karma gets you. Unless you,
unless you don't give a fuck.
If you don't give a fuck in Utero,
if you truly don't give a shit,
you got to have like a level of guilt
for common to come back and bite you in
the ass. But if you just some fucking
entitled Con Yeah, those people,
they'd skate through life.
You know? You ever see him?
You ever seen entitled can
just walk across the room.
It's like he has those little kids shoes
on. Then they had the wheels on them.
You know, they take two steps.
They just glide across the room.
They don't care about breaking hearts.
They don't care about evicting people.
Right.
They don't give a shit who fucking,
so their shirt together that out.
What does that endangered species
throw it on the grill. They don't care.
You know there's a genius to that. Just
not giving a shit. You know what I mean?
I'd love to see one of those people,
you know in the afterlife
if you have to get,
if you actually get judged just to
see the fucking look in the face,
you know what I mean?
And then God at some point would have
to feel some sort of shame being like,
well you know, at the end of the day I
assembled that. You know what I mean?
That's what I've never understood about
the judgment. It's just like, you know,
especially with these fucking sociopath's
as opposed to the levelheaded saint
that I am, these fucking, these
fucking sociopath's out there.
Like, where does, you
know, shouldn't, you know,
shouldn't you be judging God on that one?
Gingy be looking up like really,
you know,
what were you doing blow last night
if forgot to put the a I give a shit
about other people assembly into this one.
It just fucking Senate it out
there. I Dunno. The more I,
I vaguely pay attention to
all that space shit. You know,
I hate people who are in this space
by the way. There was talking about,
do you understand just
Neutrogena? It's like, yeah,
I get it. I get it in ourselves.
Understand as we fucking, we've, we've,
we've seen how gigantic it is
yet we haven't found anything.
So I still think this
place is pretty amazing.
It's fascinating is Mars
is this does nothing to do.
Yeah.
I don't understand these fucking people
that want to go to Mars and live there
and it's like,
and do what?
Huh?
Living some fucking strip mall
for the rest of your life.
Some star trek looking strip mall,
fucking drinking Tang. Just,
you can say, Oh yeah, you know,
that's your big fucking move that you
know, people want to live on Mars.
That means they suck at everything else in
life. Right. They got nothing. You know,
you know what it is. You graduate high
school, you want to come back someday,
right. And smoking a big
cigar going, hey, you know,
yeah, I was that guy used to push around
the playground, but you know what I did,
right? I went to, I did things,
I did digs and now I smoke this and
I drive dad and see that over there.
That's fucking me. Admitted it. I met her.
So usually in this day and age, that means
you're going to try to create an APP,
right? You got no Fuckin, I
don't know, get some sort of,
you start a website where you
curate videos and fucking news.
I don't know what these fucking
millennials do, but I think if you,
if you suck at that,
right?
If you can't play an instrument
and you ego could not just handle,
just being happy with what you have.
I think at that point it's like I can't
just go back to my high school reunion.
Okay.
Just being at some regular Joe.
Waking up in the morning,
putting my coffee and my thermos.
Okay.
Going into the shower and quietly crying
was the water cascades over my face and
my wife comes walking in and going
and you are right. Just be like, yeah,
he just was, I just sneezed.
I'm fine. Squashing my phone,
my phone.
I think at some point,
either you just fucking give in
and just say, hey man, you know,
being a regular guy, he's kind
of fucking cool, you know,
or you can't handle it right there.
Remind me.
I've never seen a few good men.
You get the truth. You know,
there's too many, too much gritten a teeth
in that movie. That's right. Ice Man.
I am dangerous. Right. Too much of
that shit. So I never watched it.
You know which people walking
around dressed in fucking then
little navy suit. Um, anyways,
if you can't fucking handle it and
you gotta go back to high school,
you and you've got to do something.
And I think at that point,
that's when you just say, listen,
I, I, I got to live on Mars.
I mean, I can't go back with nothing.
I got to have something to say.
That's like Lance Bass,
he couldn't handle that.
Justin Timberlake walked away from,
from in sync.
Right. Ah, dad way or
whatever the fuck they saying.
That's not where they all all
acted like puppets. Right.
He just fucking walked away, you
know. And you've got the one guy,
the goatee guy,
he's got a sense of humor about himself.
He makes all these funny
commercials. They'll do a
thing. He doesn't give a fuck.
Right.
You've got the dreadlock guy.
Did he used to bang Jennifer Aniston or
was that the other guy who's some white
guy with dreadlocks? She used to go
out with Jennifer Aniston, you know,
every one of those beautiful
celebrities always dates a guy.
And he always have that, that, that
really, you got that moment like, wow,
why didn't I learn how to write fucking
play the Ukulele and wear flip flops?
That's what I had to do. Fucking walking
around with your guardian. Mantage um,
anyways, sorry. And I think lance couldn't
handle it. He's just like, what the fuck?
You know? So then our
next thing, you know,
he's signing up to go out and
space to somehow try and outdo. Oh,
what'd you put you put out in
future sexy songs? Huh? Wait,
wait, wait. Right, wait,
wait. Where man man,
I'm going to outer space.
What?
Oh, what is it about wearing your pajamas
in the middle of the day? That just,
it just fucking opens your mind up.
You know what I mean? I swear to God,
there is no free of feeling there'd be
an a white male heterosexual still in
your pajamas at 11 o'clock in the
morning on a weekday, on a weekday.
And you know what, because I'm a liberal
con, I want everyone to experience that,
you know, all the people
in the Phillip Pace. Um,
anyways, uh, I'm actually,
I'm in a giddy mood cause I did something
yesterday that scared the living shit
out of me and I didn't die, which
is all, you know, obviously,
because I'm doing this podcast. So,
you know, I hadn't flown a helicopter,
uh,
since like October until this month.
And I flew for the first time and I could
not believe how fucking rusty I was.
How much? Just Shit. You forget.
You're like, what? Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, that's right. You know,
turn a bass tournament final.
I didn't even slow down.
Yeah,
I was so busy trying to keep the fucking
pad between the compass, you know,
and the Dashboard Day,
I can't remember what the fuck he call it,
the control panel that I forgot.
I was still doing like 65 knots
and I fucking went right by it.
I had to slam on the brakes.
Right. So, but you know,
I flew around, she'll kick off to Russia,
he's coming around, it's coming around,
you know,
so I went,
I went again yesterday and uh,
went up with my instructor and he was
like, so what do you want to do? I said,
all right, let's do the pattern.
Let's fly the traffic pattern.
Let's do some auto sets where they
simulate a main rotor failure.
That's the big fan above your head.
Like,
what if all of a sudden the
engine cuts up, you know, um,
and then those kicks left. What do you
do? You slammed the collective down,
you add right pedal, right trim, air
speed, rpm. Here come the rpms coming up,
you pull the collective up, he catch the
fucking things, you pick out your spot.
So we were doing those and at some point
I was just like, all right, fuck this.
Okay. Um, I,
I have to fly this thing by myself
or solo is they saying the business,
but I'm just a novice. So I said,
all right. He goes, well, okay,
we did a couple of those. He goes,
what do you want to do now? And I said,
all right, can, uh,
can you just step out and let me just
fly this thing around one time by myself
just to do it again? And he goes,
yeah, absolutely. So he steps out it.
Up until that point, it'd
been a great day. You know,
not a lot of traffic over there.
Everything's fucking fine. So he gets out,
roll it back up. You know, lights are out.
Our PM's are in the green gauges.
Roe, green carburetor heats up.
I fucking lift up light on the skids,
bring it up,
holding our heart right here we go. Here
we go. Cycling, wait for it. Wait for it.
Less weight in the flux. Thank
you. No fucking palms are sweating.
You know there's always that.
Dot.
I can't believe I actually fucking know
how to do this thing right. Immediately.
There's a fucking crosswind. So
I'm looking at the wind sock. La,
you fucking content. Fight
it. Left pedal. Now I'm, I'm,
I'm facing once everything's fine.
And next thing you know,
like fucking like three jet blue's I taken
off at southwest is landing. You know,
I made my call and the guy's like, you
know, whatever. Fucking six Victor Hotel.
Standby.
Standby means shut the fuck up.
I always forget that cause then I always
go six strict to hotel standing by.
So I'm fucking sitting there. I'm, I felt
like I was in a Harvard for 20 minutes.
Yeah.
What I really wanted to have happen.
It was just like one of those things
where it's like, all right, fuck this.
I'm feeling this rolled out, have
him step out. I fucking roll back up,
lifted off.
As for clarity,
gives it to me and I just take
it for a lap around the airport.
That's all I wanted to do. So now I'm
fucking sitting in this harbor just going,
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm thinking,
what the fuck am I doing?
Okay.
So finally he called. Good guy.
Fuck goes six Richter hotel la left
closed traffic of clear for takeoff.
Clever take off six Victor Hotel.
And then I uh, I fucking, you know,
took off, brought it around and when
I was turning across, when, you know,
I'm looking for traffic
to join the downwind,
make sure I don't have any problems. How
was actually thinking like, you know,
last night I did stand up dressed as
Steven Adler at the goddamn comedy jam.
I tried out a new fucking bit about
blow up dolls that was killing so hard.
I looked over and Josh,
Adam Meyers was fucking dying laughing
on the side of the stage. It's so,
as much as you make people laugh,
when you look over,
when you see a fellow comedian die and
laugh and you know you're on to something.
So then I went back and I got to play
Rhino sore dressed as Steven Adler sound,
the sound guy. Now I would have dressed up
as Matt camera, but he's just, you know,
he doesn't have any unique facial hair.
He's got that sort, that Luke haircut.
I just would've looked like me with
this stupid way gone, you know. Um,
and then I got to play the encore
paradise city and I was thinking,
I fucking did that. I did stand
up and play drums live last night.
It right now I am flying
a helicopter by myself
and I flunked so much shit in high school,
terrible at math,
fucking flood French,
all of that shit
was a great feeling. And I was
like, Oh yeah, that's right.
I'm flying a helicopter so I
get to the downwind, you know,
where'd you go across three zero. He
brings you fucking carburetor. Heat up.
See if you're fucking carburetor.
Does it freeze over in the engine?
Doesn't cut out as you slowing down.
Came around and still pulling power.
Kept my 60 knots is I turned
the fucking base in the file.
K Ryden landed,
shut the thing down nicely.
And uh, they're, my instructor
came back in and he gets, you know,
plugs his headphones in. He goes,
he goes, uh, how did that feel?
I said, I, you know, I said it was like
riding a bike except you could kill you.
Selfless.
I started laughing.
And what I've found with instructors
is they're all bad ass guys.
Every one of them chicks, they're all
fucking bad ass. This is, you know,
but the second you admit that you're
actually scared. They always laugh.
And then they usually tell you a story
how fucking nervous that they were.
But if you have some fucking cocky cunt,
um,
you don't want to do that.
Cause then what they're
gonna do is they're going to
chop throttle on you as you
fucking doing some say, hey,
yeah, I don't, I don't need that.
Even though it's good training. I've
never had anybody do that to me. Um,
but anyway,
so I did it and it made me feel
fucking amazing math. She's
like the sickest goddamn
feeling and I swear to God,
all I need to do is make
like another $40 million.
And I think I could actually afford
to truly engage in that hobby.
I in La,
it's just super expensive.
I think if you live more
in the middle of nowhere,
the big fucking thing is like just
storing the goddamn whatever you get the
plane or the helicopter.
Um,
I don't know if anybody knows like a
cheap way to do it. I would absolutely,
uh, at an absolutely
do it. But until then,
I'm just treating it like the way I
treat cars. Like I just go on the road,
you know, I go to budget
and then that's it. I just,
whatever fucking car they give me, I get
it. And I gotta be honest with you. I,
that's the one thing that bugs
me about renting helicopters.
And every time you fucking go in there,
eh, something's a little different.
You know, just be nice to
know you're fucking tail
number and not have to fucking
constantly be looking on the control
panel. Nowhere everything is no hour.
Everything works. Every radio
seems to be a little bit different.
It's just like a fucking, it's just an
extra thing. You got to like deal with it.
I wish I didn't then I'd love to just
buy one of those fucking art 20 twos,
you know, if they're funny as hell, they
just a little two seater, right? Any,
you're really flying.
It's like if you had a car that just
had drum brakes and no power steering,
like you really fucking,
you know, our holding up,
this is just what I've heard from other
pilots because I've never flown anything
fancy, nothing fancy. Like, um,
okay.
But I really fucking enjoyed it.
And uh, just even doing that,
I mean that how long it
takes to fly the pattern.
MMM.
I mean that couldn't
have been more than like,
okay.
Felt like 90 seconds. So probably, maybe
it was a little bit longer. I don't know.
But,
uh,
I dunno. It's just fucking definitely
left the place yesterday. You know,
that's one of those things where you'd
get did something great and you're
driving away and you got the window down.
Just drive when I go on.
So anyways, you guys been
watching the playoffs? Yeah,
I would say for first round playoffs.
I'll tell you the series I'm
watching obviously, and I'll say,
I'll tell you again, I'm just going
to keep saying, I'll tell you,
I'll tell you I'm watching those Celtics
in the Bulls Celtics are now up three
games to two after being down. Oh, too.
After looking like we had
no fucking answers. Right.
And uh,
which is why my nod for MVP of the
series is Rondo without a doubt.
Because the second he went down
the series just completely changed.
MMM.
And I thought all of the
Bulls had this figured out,
but evidently it was rando he
knew what the fuck was going on.
I'm giving him full fucking
credit because it's just,
it's been a tale of two cities.
You know,
it looked like they were going to sweep
us and now it looks like we're going to
run the table on them. However,
how I think Rhonda is coming back,
he took his cast off,
his suits,
have long sleeves again and um,
I can't wait to watch games.
Six I want to see like is this
guy is good is it appears in this,
in this series and a last night,
admittedly the officiating was a little
subpar and it definitely went in the
Celtics favor and I loved when Lopez
was applauding the fucking rough.
Sometimes it's worth getting a fucking
technical. I love that guy, man.
That guy comes out every night, wants
to play. He's a little fucking weird.
He's on his own vibe. He just, I, I
really liked that guy. I love what he,
it started clapping.
It's like my favorite thing.
And then they go to,
I think it actually worked
because then we went down,
they called the ticky tack fall on the
other end and you saw Dwayne Wade was
whatever the Celtics said to him. I
think it might've been, uh, Isaiah,
he just started smiling and
laughing. I swear to God, man,
I just think the NBA is
so fucking controlled.
Okay.
I really do. Just for the
simple fact that you can do it.
I've said this a zillion times,
there is no easier game to control or
fix than basketball cause it's the only
fucking game where you
can sit down as a ref.
You can take people out of
the game, you know? I mean,
I guess all the Games you can eject
somebody, but they, you know, in baseball,
football, hockey, you
really have to do something.
You just can't point it a guy and be
like, hey, go sit on the fucking bench,
but gets you can and hockey.
Right.
I Dunno.
You know what?
That's one of those things where you
think you have a good theory and then you
fucking explore all the options.
You're like, well, maybe
it doesn't work, whatever.
No, but you only sit him down for like
fucking two minutes and they come back out
and it's not like,
well,
fucking Wayne Gretzky's
got three penalties to more
and he's out of the game.
Right? Hey, you got back on track
with my theory. There you go.
He can't sit Tom Brady down.
All you've got to like,
this is what kills me about basketball.
I don't give a fuck how many points
you're up. You're up like 20 points.
He just like, Hey, this game's a Rep.
There's one quarter to go. You know,
most teams are lucky if they
score like 27 and a quarter,
that's like a fucking great quarter.
We're up by 20 all we really need to do
is score eight points and we're fine and
the next day.
Now it's just like the fucking jerk offs
are on a 27 to run every fucking time.
That whole thing. It's a game
of runs. I don't think it is.
I think it's a game of fucking ratings
and if a team gets up too high,
they just start fucking cow colon
files together. Ah, that's stupid.
That's a stupid fucking theory. But
it does, it just appears that way.
Maybe it is the nature of the game
that nobody can just blow somebody out.
Okay.
They always come back,
like I would say like 85% of the time.
Of course I didn't do any research,
but you seem to 85% of the time he
fucking belt you go up by 30 points in the
first half, you know, somehow by the end
of the game, what? Oh, Hey, what else?
Sex. One of the most
unbelievable, improbable come back
since last night's fucking slew of NBA
Games into the exact same thing. Um,
anyways,
I don't want to talk about it.
All I'm saying is that I
think a Bronto really showed,
I mean, just, I mean it's
fucking unbelievable. Like
how much the series changed.
One guy is gone and the
whole thing turns around. Um,
so I'm excited to watch games
six, even if they win, that'd be,
I like seeing greatness. I don't give
a shit. I mean I hope it's on my team,
but if it isn't that I can't and I'm like,
I can't just sit back and appreciate it.
Right.
Okay.
I tried to be a good guy, but for right
now, I don't know why I have this fucking,
this pillow that wraps around you,
this little half circle pillow,
you know when you have a baby abuse,
it's perfect. You set them down,
you give them that bottle of Jack, you
know, and then that's it. You know?
But if you try to do it with
regular pills, it doesn't work.
But for some reason I have it
around me right now. I don't know.
It feels right.
Like I don't wait to have a kid that
buy one of these fucking semi circle
pillows. Um, right. What else
did I want to talk about?
I've been watching, you know,
I've been watching the hockey.
Okay.
Gotten over the fact that my Bruins had
been knocked out by the quietest fan
based team in the league.
Right.
The team that sharing forgot until April.
Then all of a sudden they all show
up like they give a shit. Oh man,
that was fucking hard watching
that. Anyways, um, the
prejudice are looking great,
but I still think a, I don't even
if I already talked about this,
I started this podcast twice. I forget
if I brought this shit up. I still,
I'm still going with the penguins.
I think the penguins repeat. Uh,
and I Miss Anaheim Edmonton.
I bet that's a great fucking series too.
It's so crazy. They're already down
to just two series in each conference.
So I have to make sure that I'm watching,
um,
for those people last week you're like,
hey,
how come you didn't talk about Moto
GP, the race in Austin? You know what?
I didn't see it.
And uh,
then I realized I recorded it
and this is what you learn.
If you're new to moto GP and you go to
record the race and you got to fucking do
it.
It might,
it might be better than Formula One
just because of the sheer amount of like
passing in lead changes and all that.
It's fucking insane.
And then the fact he just watched
these guys falling off motorcycles.
I brought one of the races. Um,
well let me explain it first.
You're going to go to record it.
If you novice like me,
you go to record it and you'll be watching
like the first race and it will say
Modo too when they're on these little
skinny bicycle tires and you're like,
those don't look like the fucking,
you know,
those Badass bikes that I saw.
What's going on here?
Then there's Modo three and you're like,
where does the real one,
who is that Rossi, Valentino Rossi
Guy, whatever the fuck his name is.
Uh, Mike and the mechanics,
whatever that other guy's name is.
I don't know any of the fucking name shed.
So there's three different classes.
This is what I learnt.
All right.
On Moto GP as they say.
And this model to,
there's modal three and there's moto GP
and that's basically like being in Aa
Aaa and then being in the majors.
Now for whatever reason,
modal three is the lowest level. So
I guess they go in three, two, one.
I guess that's how they do it. And
they don't say one, they just say GP,
which I believe stands for Grand Prix.
I don't fucking know.
So motor three is 250
cc according to this,
this thing on reddit air to 250 cc bike,
you know,
so that's basically a cubic centimeters.
So it's a smaller engine.
It's not as fast. You know, it's still
fast as shit the way they're doing it.
But you know, that's the one like, okay,
all right there grasshopper, we'll, we'll,
you know, we'll see how he'd do at
this level. And then if you, uh,
succeed at that level,
then they move you up to moto two,
which is 600 cc's evidently for strokes.
And all the engines are made by Honda,
which I find interesting. Um, so a haunt,
they're all Honda base.
Everybody's working the exact same shit
as probably so they can truly get an
idea of who, um, who is the best writer,
who's going to get called up to the show
moto GP. And according to this person,
a lot of times in Moto Moto to the race
is better because they all just have
basically the exact same engine.
So this guy was saying you could throw,
you can usually can throw a blanket over
the top three people in that race. Um,
and then the big show is moto
GP, which is a thousand CC's. Um,
and those things are just fucking rockets.
And I watched this whole
thing on how they build them.
The handbuilt gets how much
those motorcycles cost a
piece. Take a wild guess.
Like if for some reason you
went down, they said, hey,
you want to take it for a lap,
but if you fucking trash this thing,
you got to pay for it. Okay. And they give
you that fucking suit with the airbag.
And fortunately you don't,
high side of the slide off the bike and
you get up and be like a shit or second
it costs me. I would've thought
anywhere between 102 hundred 50 grant,
you know, and I understand that it's
a fucking racing bike and all that,
but you know,
they're a little less things.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You go to to do a build on a car.
This is like fucking people
working on it on the other side.
He can't even see him a motorcycle.
I mean it's, it's right there.
Everything is right fucking there.
You want another guy can lift up
the engine and the shit is small.
If there was like a hundred, a hundred to
250 grand is what I would have guessed,
three 75 tops, right. This is like,
I'm at the showcase showdown
on the prices, right.
Ed I horrifically
underbid is what happens.
Those bikes cost $2 million each,
$2 million each. They're handmade. Um,
all this space age stuff. I watched
this whole thing on how they build them.
The gas tank is actually
underneath the seat.
What's where the gas tank usually is,
is the fuel injector.
There's an airport right in front of that,
right with the fucking front light.
Usually.
I just want to,
I watched the whole God damn thing
was absolutely fascinating and a,
I'm totally in on that sport watching
that sport and I'm watching the F one.
I don't know when the next races,
but uh, if you want to watch WWE,
I think it was a moto to race.
The last one,
this fucking guy came out of a turn is
backend started fishtailing and he went
like right up and over the handlebars
doing, I don't know how fast, I don't,
I don't get how they get up.
Okay.
Cause he,
he landed on like his foot,
he limped for a second and then he just
kinda just shakes it off. They're like,
Yay. You said foot problems
said foot problems in the past.
I'd imagine he'd had everything problems.
You fall off a bike.
You know, it's funny when I was thinking
about getting a motorcycle out here,
the stupidest thing you
could ever do, um, you know,
riding a fucking motorcycle and
how a lot of guys say, well,
you just fucking flew a helicopter.
It's, it's way safer wait state.
But there's nobody up there. I was
actually driving back. I was did, um,
mark Merrin's podcast promoting
season two of is for family.
I don't know when that's coming out.
Um,
and thank you to mark Marin for getting
me on his podcast. Had a great time.
We talked about anger, meditation, we
talk music and we help promote any,
help me promote the show.
And um, I was on my way back.
It was the middle of the day and all of
a sudden it was just all this horrific
traffic and uh, this big
fucking accident, this,
this truck had jumped at medium strip.
I don't know if the guy at meetings strip,
I don't know if the guy fucking
fell asleep or whatever,
but 10 people went to the hospital,
one person died and a dog died,
you know, so I don't know.
I just think the highway is
way, way, way more dangerous.
I said it before,
you flying in formation,
it's like you're in the fucking
blue angels. Everybody's
doing 80 miles an hour.
There's no radio contact. Nobody
knows where anybody is fucking going.
There's people texting these
people on meds. You have no
idea. And then forget it.
And then right on the other side
is another group of fucking people.
You know,
this never ending parade of fucking
people flying on the other side.
You don't know what they're going to dope.
Okay.
That fucking guy was driving a truck,
fell asleep, had a heart attack,
whatever the fuck he
did jump the meetings.
Strip went right up and over into
oncoming fucking traffic at like,
it was like 12 in the afternoon. Do you
look it up? It's on was on the five right?
In your Colorado Boulevard.
MMM.
So anyways, so I was thinking about
getting a motorcycle when I was,
I was looking up those moto GP suits,
which are like 2,500 bucks a whack,
but they got a little air
bag in him and I'm like,
well that's what the fuck I would want.
Yeah.
It'd be hilarious to buy one of those and
then by like a fucking Harley Davidson
and just look like the biggest fucking
asshole ever. You just ride that thing.
If somebody cuts in front of you, you just
let it. But there's another thing too,
is on those,
when they're racing,
you can lay it down and slide and
fucking all that stuff and you're fine.
You're fine.
It's not like you can slide into oncoming
traffic and there's a good God damn
garbage truck coming at you.
Yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno. But I miss ride
motorcycles, so I'm taking a,
okay.
There's just nothing safe about
them. I was thinking, all right,
well I'll just get it right. Dark bike.
I won't go over jumps or anything.
I'll just ride some trails. But then
every year ever every like fucking, yeah,
I dunno.
It seems like every six weeks you hear
a story about somebody riding on a trail
choosing a mountain bike though.
But if you're riding like a dirt bike
at some mountain line ends up like
pouncing on your back. Just got
the helmet on. I don't know.
I don't, I, you know, at
this podcast is going great.
It's just went off the rails somewhere.
I don't really know where. Let's,
let's do a little bit of, uh,
advertising. Indochino Jido
yeah,
the sting wreath.
The Gordon's Sumner read it Dope Chai
to talk about how every man looks better
in a suit. You know, when
I'm checking out guys at the,
at the outdoor mall, I'm like, you
know, I'm really attracted that guy,
but he's just wearing an Izod,
you know,
with some quarter Roy's, that's not my,
now look at that fellow wearing this suit.
Now there's something I could take home
to my parents that said, everybody,
if you're sick of gay men United giving
you the fucking once over or maybe
rolling their eyes, you ever think that
maybe it's not you fucking love handles.
Maybe it's the fact that
you don't have on a shirt,
a tie and a sport coat to cover up
all the mistakes you've made with you
nutrition over the last 40 years.
Thank God there's Indochino is making
it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit
and an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want, whether
it's for work, a wedding,
or another special occasion.
Here is how it fucking works.
Visit a showroom or shop online at
[inaudible] dot com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings in more.
Submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for it
to arrive in just a few weeks.
Then they'll sell all this,
your measurements and all that.
She'll sell all of that shit to these
fucking nerds making robots and next thing
you know,
there's going to be a knock at the door
and all of a sudden you're going to be
looking right at yourself.
The robot version,
you wearing the suit you wanted
and that thing's going to get,
you're going to give up your back.
It's going to fucking choke out
in no matter how much you tap out,
those robots don't care.
But this week my listeners can get
any premium Indochino suit for $389.
That's right@indochino.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for
made to fucking measure premium suit.
Three 89 bucks is not a premium
suits and nice suit. Uh,
that Indochina Doc,
that's indochino.com promo code Burra
for any premium suit for $389 and free
shipping and credible deal for a suit
that will fit you better than anything off
the rack.
Evercoat yet 389 bucks actually for a
fucking fitted suit is going to be great.
You can walk into an apple
bees and every chicken,
there's going to think you're a banker.
You got to do it. Next thing you know,
right? You fucking, you know,
you're ramming away trying to block up
the smell of that bloomin' onion that
she's been carrying around all day.
All right, lift everybody.
You know about Lyft Rye.
It's the APP that gets you a ride in
minutes on demand 24 seven for less than
the cost of a cab.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through their 10 point safety standard,
including criminal and
DMV background checks.
Unlike those other people with that
other thing that rhymes with mover,
right, you don't know what
you're going to get, right?
You could walk in there with a bloody ax.
Those fucking cunts would hire,
you know, you'll get around
quickly and safety with, with Lyft,
Lyft drivers are rated after every ride,
so only the best around you don't have
to worry about getting into a filthy car
was some creepy dude.
Everybody doesn't get a ribbon at Lyft
the way they do over it and mover with
Lyft, you can tip in the APP, which
obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean I not a dead lift.
Writers get a perfect five
star rating from the passenger.
It's just a better way. All
better. All around experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it is the fastest
growing and I inserted one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift you can get,
it's an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride. Well,
what if you're on heroin?
It's another way to to avoid nodding off
in public and then I go to school, Oh,
you're in the cab. Nobody
knows. And you know what?
A lot of people are actually getting
rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to
get around and evidently
I don't blame them.
What do you do when the
apocalypse from the zombies come?
You think you can fucking call Lyft that
Lyft drivers getting the fuck out of
there right now, Lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value in case you can't
do basic math when you enter Promo code
bill Burch as download the free Lyft app
today and enter the Promo Code bilberry
in the payment section. You'll start
with three free rides, up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bilber,
B. I. L. L. E. B. U. R.
R, no space. All caps.
All right. How many more of these fucking
things. Oh Jesus. All but he's a quick,
he's a quick, let me tell you
something like dollar shave,
club upside and simply safe.
They respect the fact that I'm
not good at reading out loud.
So these are three quick paragraphs.
Here we go.
Run on the table just like the Celtics
on the bowls. Second Rondo sat down. Bam,
Bam, Bam. Three to two Celtic, sorry.
Dollar Shave Club is the smarter choice.
You'll get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
You do a,
you no longer have to Schlep to the store
to buy a cheap disposable razors razor
that gives you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on raises with gimmicky shaving
tech you don't need.
And when you use dollar shave club's
the executive razor with the executive
razor, it comes with the date
rape drug in the fucking handle.
Some creepy banker walking around in
his gold toed socks. Shaven is nuts.
Now that's not what you do and
that's a different read. Sorry.
Did Dollar Shave Club's executive
razor with their Dr Covey's easy shape?
The blade just gently glides,
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps make the smarter choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube of
their dock.
Dick Cavett easy for only $5 with
free shipping and after that,
the raises are just a few bucks a month.
There's no hidden fees and no commitments.
Cancel anytime you want.
Join the club today@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave club.com/
[inaudible] all right.
Upside just sounds like a date movie,
right?
He wanted to go see upside.
The downside of the upside.
Do you want to go see that
stars Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan.
Hugh fucking let me get a hooker
or whatever the fuck his name was.
Who was an English guy
used to go out with Elizabeth Berkley.
It's nine Hugh Jackman.
He's the guy who was seed a whole
chicken every day to become wolverine.
I don't remember Hugh
Grant to grant you ready?
You Bet.
You may get in the fucking hooker.
Hey, I never judged that guy. He
got a hawker. Why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't you? What else are you going
to do? What else are you going to do?
What? Go home and make some fucking
Jiffy pop. You fucking Hugh Grant.
You're crushing it. You're a fucking
movie star in your own country.
You go across the pond, you
know? Oh, who's kidding?
Who England is like Modot modot
three fucking America is moto GP.
That's where you want to have you hit
movie. She guys all know it's true.
Chrysler, all steel in our blue jeans.
You all, you are, you're, you hate us,
but you love our culture.
Isn't it safe to say that I'm fucking
with you and actually emotions [inaudible]
alright. Upside. There's a better
way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com.
Every time you buy a trip it upside.
You'll save your company a ton of money
and they gave you an Amazon card worth
hundreds of dollars.
Upsides,
able to do this because they bundle your
flights and hotels together for one low
price.
That's what they do.
They rip this seats out of a commercial
airliner and they just stuff you in
there. You know, you might think flying,
standing up like you're at a mosh pit
for six hours from New York to La.
Mike Suck. He talks to me when
you that only costs you 40 bucks.
Now that's not what they do. Um, bundled
pricing saves money. This is what they do.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company saves a ton of money and
you could get thousands a year in gift
cards just for buying your air
and hotel together and upside.
You just fucking said this.
Plus you still get your miles
to what the f I feel like in the end
of that she can be missing a kid.
Neath it seems like to be too good a
deal and I get a gift card and I get to
keep my miles and I saved
them a bunch of money.
If you're shopping for business travel,
and you'd be crazy not to checkout
upside.com you're Outta your mind.
It just takes three minutes to see how
much you can say by buying your flights
and hotels together for
one low price. Oh, I see.
They both cut side deals with each other.
Somebody's gotta be doing, you know,
at some point somebody got sold
into fucking sex slavery here.
This is just too good at deal and
right now the human trade, right?
And right now when you use my name bur
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100
Amazon gift cards. Your first
trip. That's my name, bar.
To get at least $100
Amazon gift card free.
Save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip.
I love upside.com evidentaly
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details are
right. Here's the last one, everybody.
It's simply safe.
Yeah,
if you're not there when a fire starts,
simply safe can be there to save your
home off those instead of fucking throw
you into it. I wasn't there. Well, we'll
put, we'll put you right back in it.
It's kind of a good thing if you're
not there when the fire starts, right?
Simply safe can be there to
save your home. All right.
This is a robot that has a fire
extinguisher. What is this?
We simply safe home security.
You'll get a 24 seven
connection to dispatch and
lightening fast responses times
in emergencies. All right. I have to
look up dispatch. What is dispatch?
Okay.
Oh,
I know is I have 24 fucking
okay.
24 hour access to dispatch.
dispatch.com that's not what I wanted.
That's not what I wanted.
When she wished it was like voice command
on these things, then you could be,
it'd be like, what did you
want? What did you want?
Okay.
Oh, for fuck's sakes. It'll
load eventually. I'll tell
you what that means later.
Dispatch. Oh, here it is. It is a
sendoff. Oh, fucking Christ.
What just happened to come on now
and it's a low to get the send off to
destination or for a
purpose deal with the task,
the sending of someone or something
to a destination for a purpose,
so they're going to send somebody who
has a purpose in life to your house.
When it's on fire,
they're going to walk up the street
holding their fucking head. Hi,
I'm imagining that person would be driving
a fire fire engine, right? All right.
The system is easy to use
and completely wireless.
You can install it yourself in under
an hour, no installation guide,
drilling holes in your walls,
no ugly wires.
Simply safe's founder and chief engineer
thought of everything when he built
this system. Backup batteries for
your base section station, sorry,
a cellular connection to the authorities.
There are no long term contracts,
no commitments and no hidden fees.
Simply safe's round the clock.
Professional security monitoring is just
1,499 a month order today and you'll
get a special 10% discount.
Go to simply safe bird.com
that's s, I, m p l,
I s a f e burg.com for 10%
off your home security system.
Simply safe.com simply safe
bird.com sorry. All right.
Is that it?
Okay.
Is that it? I think I talked
about everything, right? Yeah.
I believe I hit everything that
I want to talk about. You know,
I was just checking in on you some
fucking music. Excuse me. That
you guys can listen to a man.
We got another like half hour of stuff
from classic podcasts from a or a Monday
and a year. A day a week gone by.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I believe there's another f one race
this Sunday. Check it out if he can. Uh,
let's go sell dicks. I'm hoping
for a classic. I hope we win,
but I also want to see Rhonda
would come on and do his thing too.
You know what I mean? Because I still
love that guy. He's still a Celtic to me.
All right. That's it. Have a great
weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Wow.
Dammit.
Hey,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
We decided to have a fucking
party for our new place.
You don't you think that was my idea?
Do you think it was my idea to have a
bunch of strangers coming into the fucking
house? I'll have people
over. That's what I do. Hey,
you want to come over and watch the
game? Nine people that I know, right?
Have all your fucking phone numbers.
You don't. Nia is a more open person.
So she's like, let's tell their party.
All right, so we still, she goes,
invite your friends. So I'm
alright. So you know I got,
you know, I'm a, I'm a guy.
I don't have a bunch of friends.
Okay.
I got six good friends for that I could
really trust, you know, it's about it,
at least out here.
Then over here,
Nia talking to her mom about all excited
about the party and she's like, yeah,
I sent it out on Facebook and
I was just like, oh my God,
did I just invite 110 people and
my heart literally sank going,
please tell me you didn't just invite
110 fucking people. She's like,
don't worry, they're not all
going to show up. It's like, yeah,
but like a third wheel and then they're
going to bring people that you don't
even fucking know. And that's exactly what
happened. It was a fucking great party.
I'm not going to lie to you, but I got
to like, I got to learn how to um, be,
I thought I was going to be a
good host. I wasn't, I wasn't.
I was all right with the people I
knew. But the people I didn't know, uh,
actually most of them were all right,
but there were a couple
of them that just fine.
It just sends you something fucking
annoying about somebody you don't know,
sitting on your God damn couch,
you know,
eating your food, drinking your
booze. He like, who the fuck are you?
It's somebody else was
laying down on the floor.
I fell like the kid's dad when we can't
even get a fucking job, right? It's over.
You're 26 she fucking pump. So
anyways, to the party is going great.
And uh, I'm basically the whole time,
you know, not drink it too much,
but I'm standing by the front tour cause
that's the only way out. All right?
And nobody's walking out
with any of my shit, right?
I'm acting basically like psycho
in fucking stripes. It's how I am.
It's how I'm wired.
All right?
So a fucking three quarters away through
the party, everything's going great.
And I'm like, wow, this is the I,
you know what? I forgot. I forgot.
I'm not 21 anymore.
I'm fucking 43.
All my friends are adults and everybody's
drinking responsibly and no one's
really hammered. Nothing got
broken. Everything's cool.
So start just as I was starting to relax,
some kid comes up to me, he's like, Guy,
yeah, you own a house. And I'm
like, well the bank owns it.
I'm fucking paying it off.
What can I do for you?
And he's like a yes,
kind of embarrassing,
but I use the bathroom downstairs and uh,
it's clogged now.
And I was wondering if he had a plunger.
And I was like,
yeah, I do have a plunger. I got a
plunger right here, the upstairs bathroom.
So I give it to the guy and I, and I say,
man, I appreciate your honesty. He goes,
no problem. He goes downstairs, he takes
care of it, comes back, he wants again.
He goes, he goes, sorry about that.
I said, not at all. Not at all.
What the fuck? It's a toilet, you
know, clogs up every once in a while.
But I appreciate it. I appreciate
your honesty. You know,
cause I would have been nasty.
Good for you. Right. So, uh,
now the couple hours goes by, the party
ends and there's like one straggler left.
And I tell this story to Nia. I'm like,
you know what, to go, what a good guy.
What a good shit. No Pun intended. You
know, he could've left it in there.
And then the other party,
I'd come walking in my fucking bathroom.
Looks like a Goddamn Port Authority
bus station, toilet, you know,
so I was psyched. So, so
one of the stragglers at the
party goes, yeah, he goes,
I saw that whole thing go down.
That's not exactly how it went down.
Like what he talking
about. He goes, he goes,
it wasn't him that was in the bathroom.
And I go, who was it? He goes,
it was his girlfriend.
Some lady
took a dump of a magnitude that
it wouldn't go down the toilet.
So now she's in there panicking and this
is when today's technology kicks in.
She can,
back in the day,
she would had to crawl out the fucking
window and hope nobody saw her and just
left the door locked. Everybody would
have panicked. Holy Fuck who's in there?
Did somebody pass out as somebody, if
somebody committed suicide? Some what?
It kicked in the door.
Alright.
Knocked it off the fucking goddamn
hinges and you go in there,
there'd be nobody in there.
You'd feel the air from outside and
then look down and everyone would see a
giant shit and be like
as a party would be over.
Okay.
And the owner of the house would
be walking around going, okay,
you bet a drive away.
Right. That's how it would,
it ended up because of today's technology.
Not saying she didn't panic,
you know,
it's even worse as a lady cause they're
not even supposed to do stuff like that.
Right.
And uh,
she was able to text her boyfriend and I
would fucking pay at least $400 to read
those texts,
the panic in those texts.
And to his credit, he
fucking, he stepped it up.
He took the hit, he
came up to me, VH ones.
I love the eighties own Belper and said,
I took a dump in your toilet to
a magnitude it didn't go down.
And I need the tools required
to alleviate this situation.
So Anti Douche bag of the week,
that guy right there.
So taking a fucking
bullet for the team that,
that right there is the
reverse Peyton manning award,
EDD and fucking go. We had protection
issue right now. He took one,
he took one for the fucking tape,
went upstairs like a Goddamn gentlemen
asked for a plunger, gave it to him.
And it was all fine and I went
down there at the end of the party.
You never would've known anything,
anything happened, you know what I mean?
Okay.
Like, uh, you know, three hours after
the Kennedy assassination. I bet it was.
It was all I'm saying it,
you know,
marked it all up and everything
was all figured out it,
but it was a nice road again.
Okay.
Mopped up the brains.
What am I talking about?
[inaudible] what's going going
on? It's bill burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 20 something 2009.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
You know, I really don't.
I really don't. All right.
I feel like shit.
Uh,
I had a really rough weekend in Columbus,
Ohio,
but before I get into the details,
I want to thank everyone who came
out on a Friday, Saturday and Sunday.
I had a great time.
I had
too good of a time. Let's
put it that way. Um,
yeah.
Too good a time to go to fucking
time and I'm paying for it right now.
You know, I don't know why I keep
doing this. I don't know why.
I just can't learn. You know?
You know I always do overrated.
Underrated on this shit. Yeah. You
know what's fucking underrated?
Eight hours sleep, you
know? You know what's,
you know what's fucking underrated going.
Hey,
you want to know the shout of
Jamison? You know what? No,
I think I've had enough.
You know what I would like?
I would like a water that's underrated.
You know?
Not going to fucking steak and shake.
It's three in the morning.
That's underrated. Yeah. One of
those fucking double burgers.
I never even made it that place before.
It didn't even look like meat like a patty
in order I've had. He looks like, sure.
We all do. We've all had a fucking burger.
Even you little Veggie cons out there,
you know what it looks like
is a little burned up wig
and there was two of them.
You know what?
I was kind of a 40 year old fucking guy
going to be 41 and fucking June goes to
steak and shake at three in the fucking
morning when he's got a God damn fucking
eight 40 in the morning flight.
Why would you do that?
Schererville you suck at math. We
all know that, but you can tell time.
I know there's numbers
involved of Jesus Christ.
What a fucking idiot. This
whole fucking day it's, yeah.
I just started thinking about that
boogie nights. I'm a fucking idiot.
I'm a fucking Eddie Eddie and I'm a
fucking idiot. I'm a fucking idiot.
Twice Friday night ended up at steak
and shake it three in the morning,
you know, fucking Sunday night.
It was as far as I didn't walk in.
They weren't like norm, like on
chairs areas again, all shit faced.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking motley crew.
You want to see a motley crew go to a
fucking steak and shake at three in the
fucking morning.
Good God Almighty.
Now I'll tell you I was part of
the problem. I was, you know what?
I bet I was doing it.
Everybody else was doing the oil sitting
in their shit face looking around
everybody else going, Jesus
Christ. Okay. Oh, that fucking guy.
Oh my God. Look at her. She's
she, she wanted slippers.
Jesus Christ.
You know you don't even realize that
doing a tier two and a have fucking guy.
Huh? Look at that. Look at
his fucking eyes. What does,
it's almost like he's been
drinking Jameson all night.
Why wouldn't you get a water after
awhile? You're a fucking idiot. Yeah.
Let me have one year burnt
up wig fucking burgers. Ah,
why is shit food so good when you,
when you shit faced, you know?
Is that what it is? Shit. Face
shit food. It's just all shit shit.
Fucking decisions. I didn't want
to do that man. I was doing well.
You know I went to trader Joe's,
you know,
dodged a bunch of fucking Bergen
stock. Hippies and I, you know,
I went in there and I, Oh I,
I got the fridge, put my room.
Fuck global warming. I want to be in
shape. I had a fridge put in my room. I,
I had got all this healthy food.
And what do I do?
What do I do?
I go out,
I go drinking to water four
nights like a fucking moron.
Oh my God. I went to this
one. You know what I had,
I had a slice of pizza last night too.
That's how fucked up I was.
This is like all coming. It's
like a slide show. You know,
you can't remember the shit that
happened in between but you just,
you just have pictures.
Good God Almighty was
at a bad look in pizza.
Is there anything fucking worse than
that? Just a bad look at it. It just,
you know, lets you know when
someone makes a pizza right in,
it even sucks when it's hot,
but then it just sits there for
a while and it just gets that,
that a cold case file look to it.
You know what I mean?
Like it should have a fucking toe
tag hanging off the crust. They,
they brought over a whole pie
to look like that, you know,
it looked like some five year old made
it in like an easy bake oven, you know,
and you're their parents and now you
have to eat it and say, oh Susie, yeah,
it's delicious. You know, just begin.
Begin her little life of people lying to
her and not being fucking honest saying,
no, don't wear that. You look fat in that
now. You just go, oh Susie, you beautiful.
That's an excellent pizza you made.
You know what, Susie? It fucking sucks.
All right. I'm not saying to give
up your dream about being a cook,
but you definitely don't fucking have
any talent at this point in your life.
You know, maybe we can send you to
some sort of, uh, of Jesus Christ.
What are those chefs schools called?
Huh? What does that art called?
You know, come on. You know what it is
because with a c, it's not custodial.
It's not common. Serac he plays for
fucking the Canadians. Canadians,
I want to say a bone, Julia to all my
friends up there in Montreal. You know,
I was just breaking your balls. I've
been blogging for the Bruins and, uh,
is basically, I went down, I was blogging
for the Bruins during the playoffs,
which I'm going to continue to do because
they swept the Montreal Canadians.
Um, and basically, uh, you know,
I have to blog for the Bruins and playing
the Canadians. I mean, what do you,
what am I going to say? The Canadian
one 24 cups. We've only won five.
We haven't won since 1972.
All I can do is just try to piss you off.
That's all I was doing. That's a Montreal
fans get really, really fucking mad.
You know, I made fun of their
coach. I just did what I get. Oh,
I just made fun how they looked,
how they blew their fucking players.
I don't even more,
I said it was just trying to be a jerk
and as people got all [inaudible] noise,
you were hooky. You
know, this guy himself,
a comedian.
I don't think this is very funny.
Whatever, you know, it's fucking funny.
I heard Celine Dion is thinking
about buying the Montreal Canadiens.
He's probably gonna move him to Vegas.
That'd be a fucking mascot on ice.
That would be, that would be a crime.
That would be a goddamn crime. All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the hangover episode
of the Monday morning podcast.
I'm sitting in a hotel in Manhattan,
New York. Why are you doing that, bill?
Huh?
You lay in low after a weekend of Busan.
Now I've got a week at Caroline's
and I'm working with Joe to Rosa.
Once again,
my partner in crime too.
Codependent fucking
alcoholics. Dino. One time,
I don't think I might have told this
story or an ONA opie and Anthony Show for
you. Uh, people who live in, I don't
know, fucking North Dakota. Um,
I don't know when that,
I was in Caroline's Caroline's comedy
club on Broadway where I will be Thursday,
Friday, Saturday and Sunday
for a fucking 22 shows,
22 fucking shows. I couldn't even do one
show at this point. I'm laying low, man.
I'm laying low. Um, but
anyways, one night I was,
I was standing there at
the bar and I decided,
I didn't know if I decided I wasn't going
to drink, but I just wasn't drinking,
you know, and all of a sudden who comes
walking down the stairs, you know,
like some starlet in the 1950s
making a big fucking debut,
Joe de Rosa. Do you think it was missing?
Was the fucking the evening gown.
He comes fucking Walson down the
stairs, you know, all dainty, like,
and the second I saw him, I was
like, fuck, now I got a drink. Right.
And you know what, he was
thinking the exact same thing.
That was the funny thing.
Neither one of us wanted to drink. You
got any friends like that? You just,
you just been fuck ups for so long that
neither one of you can just pull you out
of the tailspin. I'm sure.
Anybody who's been in Aa good.
Tell me what exactly that that's called,
what kind of friendship that is?
Um, I don't fucking
know. I really, I really,
really feel like shit right now. And,
uh, so I'm setting the room and, uh,
if you notice the quality
might be a little bit better.
I actually got a microphone now and
I have a little mixer and I have my
headphones on and I'm sitting here
in the fucking dark. That's not true.
I got the one little desk light on,
uh,
basically talking to myself. You know,
technically once you start listening,
this whole thing makes sense.
But Right now before I upload this thing,
this is really, uh, you know,
this is why they don't give
everybody handguns. Because
if one was laying around,
I'm fucking with you.
You know what I would do?
I'd probably pointed out the window.
I wouldn't shoot anybody.
Just trying to scare someone,
maybe make me laugh and I could get a
little oxygen or something into my fucking
head. What do you guys do? What do
you guys use for hangovers? Huh?
Other than the smart thing,
not drink anymore. Goddamn.
It's just so much fun though. You know,
I was having a great time, you know,
there was broads, you know,
just having a good fucking time.
Just a good time. You know, it's other
fucking people who like to drink.
I met a couple of hunters. I am at
a couple of dancers. I, you know,
I met a, you know, a nice mix of people
that I'm a fucking weird dude man.
I don't like people before I get on stage,
like I don't want to see them.
I don't see anybody in the fucking crowd.
But the second the show's over,
if somebody is cool,
I that's the part of the show I I enjoy
and I become like this fucking a Charlie
rose and I just started
interviewing people, you know,
what's it like to shoot a pheasant in the
face? Hmm. What's that like? You know,
do you got a little fucking couple of
pieces of wood that you're rub together
and somehow it sounds like a pheasant
going a Eddie come on over here, you know,
or whatever. The fucking pheasants
names or if you had a pet pheasant,
what would you name it? Huh? Larry? That'd
be a great name for a pheasant as it be.
Funny if you had it right.
And people looking at it.
Oh my God, is it a pheasant?
Like Larry, get the fuck off of that
thing. Actually got off of it, you know,
and then he got on a late night talk
show and then you went out there and then
it didn't work.
And then the host sorta mugged about how
it didn't work and then maybe it takes
a turd on his fucking wing tip shoe and
50 years later it's part of the greatest
hits DVD,
you know.
And little did you know that that was
the pinnacle of your life is a fucking
zookeeper.
That one moment you thought it was going
to keep happening and no one episode
one episode and you never asked back
because your animal shit on the fucking
host shoe wasn't supposed to
do that. It didn't. It do.
They didn't do it in the rehearsals.
All right,
how the fuck am I going
to maneuver this year?
All the rattling in the background,
I couldn't move my mixer or you know,
I feel right now I feel like
the fucking Unabomber, all this.
God Damn was he anti technology though.
I don't know if he was anti or pro at all.
I know he was definitely fucking alone
and it was a paranoid son of a bitch.
Yeah,
my back. There we go. Did you guys
get nervous there for a second?
What the fuck?
There's too many fucking courts here.
I'm going to go back to this cell phone.
I'm not on holding my fucking laptop
like a God damn, you know, you know,
like servants used to hand shit to kings.
Would they put something on a pillow
and then they had the little hands
underneath it? That's the way I'm
holding it. I'll tell you what,
can I paint a fucking picture? Can
I paint a goddamn picture? Let me,
let me adjust the microphone. I want to
tell you about my microphone. By the way,
do you remember back in the
1970s, you know, nowadays,
whenever somebody has a mic,
uh, and they have like a little
filter on not a filter, whatever,
I don't know the technical,
you know,
little spongy thing that you stick on
there so it doesn't pop or if there's some
sort of wind, you know, nowadays that
just black and it just looks like a,
you know, fucking giant
just sitting there, right.
Something that they can put it on TV, you
know. But back in the day, man, the 70s,
you know,
when people buy and we'd buy the
fucking garbage bag full and uh,
you know, the 70s were colorful man,
you fucking day just start it off.
You know,
he had that crazy cereal that they used
to have somebody brought up bu barrier
count. Chocula and Franken Berry and I
was in the cereal aisle. Uh, you know,
the other day when I went,
when I went to trader Joe's,
when I was going to have a healthy week
before I down five bottles of whiskey on
the worst drunk too.
I'm one of those guys,
I fucking call up people and start
telling them I love him, you know,
and one of those guys, you know, I,
I do everything but end up in the drunk
tank on the fucking Andy Griffith show.
I'm such an old school drunk,
but I'm not an angry guy when I get drunk.
I'm really not. I'm actually
pleasant and I'm able to emote.
Is that why you do it,
Bill? I don't fucking know.
All I know is it makes me feel like shit
the fuck was I just talking about? Oh,
how coke colorful the
seventies where yeah,
you'd start off with that fucking
cereal that they had and uh,
it was one of the worst sentences ever.
Yeah.
He started off with that cereal
that they had. Oh, they had go bell.
It's a great way to, to fucking
start it off. Right. If you,
Patty yourself on the back about how many,
how you could paint a visual, you know,
it's funny,
I have headphones on right now.
I have no idea how a lot I'm talking and
I'm sure that there is somebody on the
other side of this wall that is
contemplating calling the front desk,
but what they're listening
to is so fucking bizarre.
They haven't been able to tap out yet.
Well that's arrogant pill.
Maybe they're listening and your sound
fucking annoying. All right. Whatever.
Stop Heckling yourself. Get to
the point. Yeah, you start off,
we'd eat tricks that you need. Booberry
the shit literally changed the color.
Your milk,
which is some really hacky comedy from
fucking the 80s but I'm telling you,
you had that shit going on honeycomb,
you know the co the fucking
people were wearing polyester.
I mean Shit was loud in the 70s
you know those plaid slacks,
people had slacks, he had boots had set
up the side. They were all fucking shiny.
Women had like those, those plastic
looking purses. It was fucking freaky.
It was weird.
Everything was like done.
Suddenly I think the
advertisers just like, look,
everybody's on drugs so we really
need to enhance their trip.
So much shit in the 70s was like really
done to like even like the fucking
monkeys,
which I guess you know was that this?
That was the late sixties I think it went
to the early seventies we were wanting,
when they used to fucking,
you know, pretend to sing in,
pretend to play instruments at the
end of the show there and they would,
they would cut to that little musical
montage has and they'd always do like half
the time they would do like those,
they'd put it in like a kaleidoscope.
So you had them actually in the middle
and then like six of them like going
around like a fucking, like a fucking
revolver aside. I don't know what it was.
And you're eating that cereal. He
just watching the shit. Anyways,
this all comes around to my microphone.
Back then you couldn't even watch like
a sports show without sort of tripping,
you know what I mean?
Like they had ABC's wide world of sport
and they had these fucking bright yellow
sport coats on and they used to have
these microphones and when they stood
outside, the little spongy thing
that they stuck on top wasn't black.
It didn't blend in with the microphone.
There were these crazy colors.
And one that I always remember was
there was always like bright orange.
It made no fucking sense.
But as a kid I liked it.
So whatever.
I bought a microphone and the guy goes,
what kind of wind screen do you want?
You know you want the standard black one?
I said, fuck that. I want that one.
Keith Jackson used to use when he do
Monday night football way back in the day
or Redo the college games. You remember
Keith Jackson? Huh? Hello? Again.
Everybody that says kicked Jackson.
Remember that guy? Alabama,
Crimson tide and I'm fucking
wolverines and Michigan.
They're going to be swapping paint. Um,
anyways. Yeah, so that's what I got here.
That was a really long fucking
way to go to explain that.
I put an orange spongy thing and the
end of my fucking mic, and I'm a Jew.
I know I'm cursing a lot right now and
I'm cursing. I'm not cursing at you guys,
okay? Sometimes people get
confused. It's not cursing at me.
I'm not cursing at you and cursing at
my hangover because I described shit to
you. All right? Jesus Christ. Look at
this fucking fake wood in this desk.
This is the kind of desk that you sit,
you know that you sit at when
you're like confessing to a murder.
You know what I mean? He just sitting
in and trying to wear you down.
They bring in some food and I can like,
they're your friends.
I was just watching those fucking cold
case files, man. God damn loose things.
A creepy just fucking creepy.
Just watching the people when they
come in and they, and they, and they,
they getting questioned for the murder
and they just sound like, you know,
regular, regular guys. Where
were you that night? Oh, you
know, it was home. You know,
watching a basketball game,
you know, just chilling out
at a pizza out.
He fucking hacks up 23 people.
Then when the, when they, when they admit
it, they're like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
he did it. You know, they, they
found this one guy that, uh,
who's that fucking guy that
the green river, I don't know.
They always got to give them nicknames,
the fucking news so they
can sell more papers.
They give them nicknames like they're
going to the rose bowl or some shit,
you know, crazy legs. Johnson,
he's killed 48 fucking people.
They call them the ice
man. Um, anyways, so there,
there's one guy up in Seattle,
right? He killed all these,
all these women who was brutal and uh,
they picked the guy up.
He never been arrested
before and they, they, they,
they meet him outside of his job
cause they put together a case. Okay.
He has no idea that they're
onto them. And they got, they,
the cops come up to the guy and they
say, listen buddy, uh, where, you know,
fucking whatever the police officer's,
I choose to try and get a headache.
I don't know what the fuck they
say. You know, they say hi,
we're cops and we're here to arrest
you for the murder of four women. Now,
if you've never been arrested before, when
your heart drop, the guy just is like,
I guess evidently he just went, oh,
okay. Then they brought him down there,
he confessed to that and he confessed to
like fucking 60 other women that he had
killed. So they bring this guy into, uh,
another run to talk to what?
To a psychologist, you know,
cause he wants to try to break them down
so you can figure out so you can stop
these maniacs. Right. And He, they asked
the guy this question, they said, uh,
you know, if you could, um,
you could pick out one thing about your
personality that you feel is different
from the average person walking
down the street, what would that be?
And without missing a beat. The Guy said,
ah, that whole, that whole caring thing.
Wow. You know when you think you
don't give a fuck Jesus Christ.
Just regular. Yeah, the whole Karen,
that whole caring thing. Yeah.
I just don't seem to give a
fuck. It's weird. You know?
I don't know. I hate watching that. I
don't know why I watch that show it show.
It literally gives me nightmares.
You know what I mean?
You start thinking about what?
This is not funny.
What the fuck am I talking
about? See, this is what happens.
This is what happens when
you go out boozing. I,
you know what the sad thing
is is I know at some point,
at some point this weekend I'm
probably going to do this again,
but fortunately I'm in New York City,
so I want to end up at a steak and shake.
I have never eaten there. I think
I've made fun of that fucking place
on these podcast. How would you rate,
how would you guys out there? Huh?
All my listeners out there, please tell
me you listen and please tell me I'm not.
I'm done.
Just sitting here baking under this
fucking hotel lamp for nothing.
How would you rate the worst?
Your worst?
Like a fast food, you know
what I mean? Everybody, you
know, no one wants to eat it,
but we all need it. Cause you know,
it tastes good. Fucking tastes good.
But then there's this certain ones,
either you had,
either you had a bad experience or
you, uh, just the look of it. You know,
I got, let's say for me like Taco
Bell, I just can't go in there.
There's just something about the colors
on the sign that it just makes my
stomach hurt. You know, you just get that
awful feeling in your stomach. You know,
I fell the same way about like Arby's.
He's never fucked with Arby's and
Mcdonald's guy. I'm old school,
like Mcdonald's
in and out as the shit.
But you know, I got a lot of
memories as a kid at Mcdonald's.
So I think that one's still wins even
though in and out is even better.
But there's just certain ones I won't
even go into, you know? All right guys,
I'm fucking and fast. Jesus Christ.
I need a fucking water or something.
The hell did I do with that water?
Didn't I have water around here?
Hang on a second.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Fucking water I should had
last night. All right, let's,
let's get on with the questions here.
Um, it's, you're new to my page.
You probably think I'm out of my
fucking mind and you would be right.
I am out of my mind. But you
know what? You know what?
I don't have anything to say to that.
I have guilty as charged.
What are you fucking perfect. Why don't
you go to, it's a tough fucking www.
I'm fucking perfect.com and
go listen to that podcast.
I bet there's a lot of fucking laughs on
that one. You know? Did they got a mixer?
I got fucking mixer.
Bitch, you liked that shit.
I'm learning a lot of computer stuff.
You know what?
How about you guys make me computer
literate? Can you do that for me?
I'll start off with something really easy.
Something that really fucking annoys
me on my computer. And you know what?
Maybe someone else does this
and maybe this is a noise.
Someone else who has a computer who
also has a drinking problem. Okay.
And then, uh, you know, I'll read how
to do it. Maybe I can help something,
another drunk out there. All right.
This is one of my problems that I have
when I go to you when I go
into to apple works, right?
The text is so fucking small. I
don't understand it. It's set.
I know how to change it, but I got
to change it every time. All right.
Right now it's stuck on 12th okay.
Which is basically squint size and you
don't want to copy and paste your guys'
emails into my fucking thing.
It's it, it, it makes it smaller.
I don't know what it's doing.
I wanted at 18 I want the default
set at 18 how the fuck do I do that?
And apple works. I got a
brand new MAC book. I want to
learn how to do that. Okay.
I want to learn some shit. You
know, I know how to upload.
I know how to do this now. Look at
me. I don't want to upload shit.
I'll turn it into a fucking MP.
Three I'll send it right to you.
I know how to do that now.
I feel great.
It's my new opening line when
I hit on checks on the road.
You know what's up, sweetie? How
you doing? You'd like to show,
do you know I can also upload audio
files and turn them into an MP three.
Huh? Put it on a desktop. A
fucking drag it right over there.
Same Way. I'm going to drag you
across the fucking carpet in my hotel.
What the fuck is that? All right. Can
somebody teach me how to do that, please?
Okay, and let's get on with the podcast
it. You know what the problem is?
Is this not enough fucking
room here? Oh, I got it.
Why don't I just move this dude,
I even have a little stand
here from my microphone.
I have a little fucking stand.
This is like a, I don't know.
This is one of these like really nerdy
things that if you start when you're 18
by the time you're 30 you're famous
and you're not a nerd anymore.
Like chicks wanna fuck yet. So it's
unreal, but when you start this at 40,
it's just pathetic and
sad. Okay, here we go.
We're going to go to a, I already did
the underrated. So why don't I do over?
Um, I know this is really, this is
really coming off grumpy. I understand,
but whatever, you know,
last week I was pissed.
This week I'm grumpy. You know what? I'm
due for a happy one. How about next week?
Next week I'll be all bubbly.
I won't be cause I'll be flying across
this country. Oh man, that's gonna suck.
Let's not think about that.
Do you know like I literally
fall asleep on the plane.
I've flown across this country so many
fucking times that I can literally look
down and pretty much guess
what state I'm over. You know,
as a passenger I can do that. Why these
levels so low but the fuck is going on.
There we go. Might not talking into
this thing. Hello, test. There we go.
You know what I mean? I can
look out, I can tell, you know,
pretty good. I mean, Rick,
yeah,
I dunno. Wait a minute. What the
fuck am I bragging about? What?
Southwest is a desert. You get into
Colorado, you've got the mountains,
starts getting flat. You're like,
all right, this is Nebraska, Kansas.
Maybe we're in Iowa. You start seeing
more lights. You moving towards fucking
into Illinois, right? And that
all works. I don't fucking know.
Like I actually like I
recognize like lakes now.
You know, I can look down at my watch.
Oh, you know what? It's taken this long.
We're right about here. Eh, we should be
seeing Cleveland coming by. There it is.
There it is. I look down sometimes
and look at fucking stadiums. Okay,
so all my fucking life is now.
If I could be outside the plane and look
at my stupid roundhead looking at that
little oval fucking window.
This is what I signed up for.
This is how fucking hung over I am.
I'm actually bitching that I'm a comedian.
Something that I wanted to do, wanted
to do something that I decided to do.
All right,
Jesus Christ.
There was a way for you guys
to email me a fucking tampon.
I think I get like 9 million this
week. All right. Uh, here we go.
Let's read the a overrated. All
right, let's get into your thoughts.
I think you've heard enough from me for
one week. All right. Overrated bill.
All right. Build a, I
think this is overrated.
A lot of people don't talk about this.
This is coming from a woman. She says,
male strippers are overrated.
She said,
especially when they are hired
a for a Bachelorette party.
Is it me or does, uh, uh, Jesus Christ,
I can't read when I'm fucking
not hung over. She goes,
is it me or does anyone else think this
is the stupidest waste of 125 bucks
they've ever seen? You guys get
stretched. 125 bucks. Jesus.
Is there anything that sucks about being
a woman? Yeah. Given birth periods.
All right. You're right. You're
right. Sorry. Um, yeah. Okay.
Well let me get back to
this. Yeah, the guys are all,
the guys were all muscled up and
everything, but to be honest,
when you see women looking
at male strippers and they
are hooting and hollering
and laughing and laughing it
up with their girlfriends,
they're actually laughing at the stripper.
Yes,
it is true that they are likely some
women who enjoy it and thinking this guy
would probably be awesome in bed,
but 95% of women are hysterically laughing
at the Ridiculous Man All oiled up
and his g string with his stupid little
boombox playing NXS what you need,
Jesus Christ. Yeah. She just, hey, it
go. She's painting a picture there.
That's what you need and a good story
and you need a narrator who's not fucking
grumpy and hung over anyways,
playing what you need.
Gyrating around the living room
and dry humping. Dad's lazy boy.
You know what? Jesus Christ, uh,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
This is really fucking long. Let me
get to the point here. She says, women,
what women want is women
want a man who was a man,
kills spiders, drink beer, et cetera.
None of us would picture our man acting
like a sex machine with a wax chest
dancing in front of a group of housewives.
A man will offer my girl a man will offer.
My girlfriend is a stripper
and he knows his buddies.
We'll congratulate him like God, Dude, you
go friends and stripper. That's awesome.
A woman would never offer
the same information. Why?
Because she knows the response from other
woman would be a snicker and a yikes.
Gee, I'm so sorry. Look, is that true?
The women really not like
don't just like cougars,
don't they like male strippers?
You know?
If you want to know what it's like
to be a guy, be a woman in your,
as far as like our sex drive,
you know,
I think maybe a woman once you're
in your forties at that time.
I don't even what the fuck
point I'm trying to make there.
I just know that like older women
act like the same level of retarded.
That guys act like
our entire fucking wise.
When they start to get older. I don't
know what it is. I guess it's safe.
They finally don't give a shit.
And they could admit that they like
cock or they like sex, you know,
cause before they have to be like,
well you know,
it's just for procreation or I
just like my boyfriend's cock.
I don't have any other fucking fantasies,
you know?
Whereas guys we just get,
we just get to be pigs.
We just get to be the God damn pigs
that we are. But you know what?
You get to cry at movies and get
that shit out. I get to hold it in.
You know what? There was a rough
one was that Harvey milk movie.
The amount of Shit I had to think about
so I wouldn't tear up during that movie
just so I wouldn't be feeling, you
know, as a guy you can't fucking cry.
So I got to sit there and be like, you
know, he's, he's going through some shit.
I know everyone was getting all sad when
a, you know, when he gets whacked there,
you know. So in order not to get emotional
myself, I just thought, you know what,
if someone just came over and
just kicked him right in the balls
and I just started laughing,
you know, that's what it is.
That's what comedy is. It's to
stop from crying. All right.
Um, number two. Oh, this
is, oh my God, this,
some New Yorkers aren't
going to like this one.
This is another thing that she
says is overrated is underrated.
Actually, a two run homer
in the bottom of the ninth,
ninth after Mary off of Marianna Rivera.
And I could've fucking read that better.
Yeah. The red sox swept the Yankees fans.
Fucking unbelievable. There'll be
back. This shit always happens.
One team always jumps out in
front of the other team, right?
Do we fucking all you guys?
We fucked the all new goes
and then they literally
almost like it's fixed now.
The Yankees will sweep us down there and
we'll play each other like 12 times or
13 times and someone will win
when it fucking seven to six.
It's a God damn business people. Okay,
there's no fucking Santa Claus, honey.
I don't buy it. Um, and we
stole home plate and you know,
how the fuck does that happen? $200
million team. You know something.
You realize the red sox sale,
they only there number four this
year as far as money spent. Oh yeah.
A lot of you fuckers didn't know that.
Dead you Yankee spent 200
million then it's the maths.
Then I believe the cubs and then us.
We're 122 million. Isn't that great?
Now we're going to act like we're some
little fucking starving panty little
Pansy fucking team.
Yankee did ruin in baseball.
Um, who gives a fuck? I'll tell
you what's funny is of the, the,
the fuck did I just do there? I
sit on my computer. All right,
let's let you know what
I'm really starting to feel
like I'm losing the momentum
of this 31 minutes. 31 hung over minutes.
Dude. I'm going to tell you right now,
this is feeling like four hours.
I feel like I'm doing a
fucking telethon right now.
Let's get to the questions for
the week. I got a, I got one here.
Am I the only one who thinks Terry
Francona is glasses make him look like a
cancer stricken Mrs Claus,
he's the, he's the, uh,
he's the manager of the red sox.
I did see him. Yeah. Those, they,
they're definitely a, yeah, he looks
like he should be at the very least, uh,
you know, going out Carolyn or something
reading the night before Christmas.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know. You know,
I talked a lot about sports last week
and a couple of people really got pissed
just talking about how dumb they are.
Some guys since this,
this huge fucking rant about saying how,
you know,
being into a sports team is
almost as dumb as patriotism.
I know the point you're trying to make.
You know what I mean?
I get it. You know, I know what you're
saying, but you know what the fuck dude.
I mean, I've done like almost
two years of these things.
Eventually sports was going to come up
that we always have to talk about what
you want to talk about. This
guy was really, I dunno,
sometimes I don't know if people are
going for Douche bag of the week.
I don't know what do I
have anything else here?
I don't think I have anything else. Oh,
Bill, I need some advice. All right,
here's another guy. Obviously he had
some Jamison. Listen to this shit.
This is his question. Hey
Bill, big fan bombed right now.
I didn't get that for a second.
I thought like he said,
big fan and he meant like that line bomb.
But evidently he means he shit faced or
he's the worst speller anywhere in the
world. Here we go. It starts
off. It says, anyways,
I need some objective viewpoint.
Me and this hot chick,
I'm a big old,
ugly rugby player recently
started hanging out.
He misspelled that and we like, no, he,
he put the e at the beginning of each.
We like each a lot.
Jesus Christ. Dude recently started
hanging out. We'd like each other a lot.
My problem.
She used to date a black guy.
I have black friends. My buddies
will tear me apart. Thoughts,
advice. Thanks John. Well,
John,
um,
my thoughts are you're pretty
fucking shit faced when you a,
when you sent that email that that's my
thoughts cause the rest of it makes no
sense. She used to date a black
guy. Okay. You have black friends.
Is that supposed to establish
that you're not racist?
My buddies will tear me apart
like what?
They're going to in a good natured way
revue that your deck isn't going to be as
big. I don't know what you're
trying to say here. Tell you what,
why don't you fucking,
you know,
don't email me now cause I know you're
feeling the way I'm feeling. But you know,
sober up trying to clean that
up. You know, I think maybe
you got something there.
Send me a second draft. I
Dunno. What the fuck that means.
She used to date a black guy.
How to fuck would they know
you have black friends? My buddy will
tell you where your black friends.
Do they know this guy?
Did she used to date one of the,
one of your friends who was black?
That's just a weird statement.
I have black friends. Do you have
black friends? Sure. We all do.
Like you're trying to load yourself
some sort of credit credibility.
The fuck does that made anyways? You
know, how many friends do I have?
Joe To Rocio, he's half of Gypson.
So that takes care of the, uh,
does that take care of Arabs?
Are Egyptians considered era and what
the fuck Arabs are? I don't even know.
I don't fucking know. I
can't, I, you know, I dunno.
I don't [inaudible] be an innocent,
one question I've always is being Jewish
is that, I know it's a religion. Is it a,
is it a race? It's not a race. Right?
I would want to take a
long time ago, I, I, I,
I was in high school and one of
my friends was Jewish, right?
And uh, I said to him, I said,
what are you, what are you Italian?
He goes, no, I'm Jewish. And
I, I could tell I offended him.
So I didn't do a follow up question,
but in my head I'm going, okay,
Italian is a race. I thought Jewish was
a religion. I know Jewish is a religion.
You know that doesn't make any fucking
sense. I don't fucking know. Let's,
let's read a revenge story.
Let's read or event story and
let's fucking wrap up this podcast.
This is going to be a shorter one.
This is the hung over version. Oh,
here's something else I came up with is I,
I'm actually contributing underrated.
You know, it's underrated. Free Internet
in the hotels. God Damn. And I liked that.
I wrote all that other shit in anger, so
let's not read that. All right, here's a,
here's a big long revenge story to end
the podcast this week and let me know
what you guys think about the sound.
I know kind of a in my head a little
bit and I got this mic like stationaries
that affecting the sound because God
knows I'm not going to go back and listen
to all this shit. I usually
listen to them, but not this
week, man. Not this week.
I've done it for a fucking week. I
don't want to tell you, you know,
this is one of these times, so it's
great. I don't have a kid, you know,
because I would have no patients for,
you know,
it's a new bit I've been working on in my
act, talking about how much I like, uh,
I like kids when they're, I like kids
the same way. Like, I like dogs. I like,
I like them when they're puppies
and they're full of life, you know?
And once they get a little bit older
and stubborn, they think they know shit.
It's just, it's fucking, they're
annoying. You know? I like kids like, uh,
your fucking cracks me up.
I saw this kid the other day,
this kid was like two years
old, right. You know, it's
funny about toddlers, right?
How they did, I talked about this already,
how they got their little fucking,
they got, they already have a beer belly
and they never even drank. They look,
you know, look, these
little fucking truckers,
it always is just fucking makes me
toddlers fucking beer bellies just fucking
make me laugh every time
I say, oh, you know,
it's because they're not self
conscious about their bodies.
They don't give a fuck.
So they just got it hanging out there
like some fucking drunken slob at a
barbecue. You know, they just,
it's just funny to me.
They look like they've already fell.
They fucked up in life. You
know, like they're gambling,
they're eating the wrong food. I don't
know. Why do they have those fat bellies?
Jesus Christ. You're eating mush
in milk. You'd, you're the first
one. I just admit, I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about sometimes.
I'm literally sweating right now because
of a lamp. That's how fucking hung over.
I am. Okay. Here we go. You
know something else I hate.
I mean, this is something I've been
doing. I've been, I've been trying to eat,
you know, one just veggie
meal a day, you know,
to then I can make up
for the fucking oxen.
Then I'm going to eat later on that
night or evidently the fucking steak and
shake. Then I'm going
to eat and uh, you know,
I can't stand about those fucking veggie
meals. I ordered this Veggie meal, right?
I ordered a, uh, uh,
some sort of fucking horrific veggie wrap,
which really sucked because they
grilled the vegetables. You know,
like when you go beyond where
they start becoming mushy,
it just, uh, I can't even say what it
sounds like. What it, what it tasted like.
It's gonna make me fucking gag here, but
you know, it just, I'm going to do it.
You know what? If you're squeamish,
cover your fucking ears right now.
You know what it tastes
like when when you,
they over steam vegetables
or they fucking uh,
over grill. I don't know what
it gets all squishy and mushy.
It tastes like it's pre chewed.
Just pausing right now,
waiting for the grounds.
People thrown their headphones off.
All you people want to lift the cold side.
Did you just grown?
Do they had the fat
Harry Fuck next to you?
Start looking at you wondering
what you're listening to. Um,
this is what I hate your yard or a Veggie
wrap. Orion. They go one veggie wrap.
I ordered some soup like an old
fucking Jewish man in Manhattan. Right.
And then,
then what happens?
They bring it to me and as they got
French fries on the side, it's like,
can't you see? I'm trying,
I'm trying to get in shape.
I understand it's a French
fry. It's a potato. It's a,
it's a vegetable. I get it.
What the fuck? It's like when
you go to the cheesecake factory,
order a salad and then they go,
would you like to third? It's like,
do you not get the fucking
theme here lady? Do you not
see what I'm trying to do?
Do you see my bloated
alcohol infused face?
Do you understand what I'm trying
to do here? I actually, you know,
it's not even fair cause I actually
talked to one of those, uh, Gsk,
I think I was making fun of the
cheesecake factory and now my act and um,
there actually was, there was a
waitress in the crowd as always.
I always end up shitting on something
and then someone from the crowd is like,
Hey, I do that. What the fuck?
So it was this cheesecake factory waitress
and she came up to me and she said,
uh, she goes, actually, they
make us do that. We have to
do that. If we don't do it,
we get fired.
Really?
Is that what it's come down to?
That that's where the
decisions in your life led you?
That you have a job that if
you don't ask people for cake,
which is usually a nice fucking thing to
do. If you don't do it, you get fired.
They have a gun to your fucking
head to basically have your job,
to try to make people become diabetics.
Is that what's going on?
Is that what happened in your life
because you sucked at something in school?
You know? I don't fucking know. All right,
let's get on with the revenge story.
I am fucking,
I know why I shut off the air.
Is anybody else just
hate air conditioning?
I don't mind air conditioning when it's
9,000 degrees out, but when it's fucking,
you know, it's like, I don't know
what it is. It's like 65 degrees out,
70 72 and they got the air
conditioning on. It's like,
are you trying to give me pneumonia?
Huh?
Is that what the fuck you're trying to
do? Jesus Christ. Am I in a mood? Hey,
what do you guys think about
that? Swine flu? You know,
this might be a little comfortable,
controversial, but I'm kind of all for it.
I think this is another time where we're,
we're getting in the way of nature running
it's course nature is trying to kill
off us.
Not all of us,
but some of us so that you know,
there's no traffic. You
know what I mean? It's,
it's like the forest fire. It's a
rebirth. You know, you burn it down.
Some animals die, some trees die.
You get rid of all the brush.
It's like a spring cleaning. That's all
a plague is. It's just that we, you know,
you don't want any loved ones to die.
Okay?
Plagues and I'll tell you, man
plagues that there are really, uh,
they're fascinating. They're putting
out all these stats. You know what?
Fuck this revenge story. Let me go on
the Internet here. Let me, let me, uh,
let me restart Firefox. Now. What is
your fucking problem? I never stopped it.
I'm in the middle of a podcast.
Got Damn these fucking computers.
What do they do? This shit to me. Come
on, let's go. Anyways. Yeah, they would,
they'd given up all, all these, uh,
all these statistics on a plagues
and that type of stuff. Every dental,
he didn't know it was like,
like 675,000 people died in the United
States in 1918 because of like an eye
influenza, whatever the fuck that is.
I didn't know what the fuck that is,
but everybody got it.
And a whole bunch of people died.
And you know what's fucking,
you know what's fucked up about
that was thank God they did.
You know, cause if they didn't
they all would have fucked.
Yeah.
And they would have made more fucking pee.
We might've been where we're at right now.
We might have been there 15 years
earlier. I love, I just throw numbers out.
I'm, I like, I'm a fucking scientist
here. I don't want, I'm talking about,
hang on a second.
Let's look up plagues.
It's going to get me on
some sort of FBI list.
You know I need to do now is Google
fucking anthrax and it'll be a knock at my
door and I really will be confessing
at this fucking table here.
Great plagues
and history. Okay, that
should be a great game show.
That's every a fucking great
game show. Okay. Is you tried it.
You start googling shit and whoever
gets the FBI to come to your place first
wins and you can't do like
easy shit like uh, like yeah,
obviously any sort of creepy pedophile
stuff cause that's just fucking horrific
and it's, it's never funny is it? Even
though I joke about it on stage sometime.
All right. List of historical
plagues. Let's go to Wikipedia.
God knows they're always number one.
All right.
In human history,
the term plague refers to an epidemic
disease causing a rate of mortality,
a pestilence and academic. Daesh. Shut
the fuck up. I want to, I want stats.
Okay. What? I've got to go
to MLB, I've got to go to CBS
sports.com so I got to go.
Ongoing danger.
Great plagues of Athens.
Let's get to some recent ones here.
You know, what do we got here?
Great plague of Iceland.
See what I'm saying?
Everywhere everybody had a plague in it.
Then the herd,
great plague of Portugal, great plague
of Russia, great plague of Ireland,
Scotland,
London plague.
Just attack the fucking
city for two years.
1592 to 1594 the Italian plague.
Everybody's fucking had one. It was
last time we had a plague. You know,
we just say that you just can nip it
in the butt with, with, with fucking,
with the media. They just, they get it
out there before it gets a chance to, to,
to help with the traffic.
You know?
So I'm in New York City right
now and they have a number of,
a number of cases out in Queens. And, uh,
you know, they're telling people
how, you know, what's funny as hell.
They tell people,
did you use common sense?
If you feel like you're getting the
flu, go to the hospital. Right? So they,
they say, you know, if you
sneeze or if you cough,
just covering your mouth. Right? So half
hour later I'm walking down the street,
walking down whatever fucking
avenue here in New York,
and I see this kid on a bicycle and he
proceeds to sneeze and he just turns his
head and it looked like a fucking spit
take. And I just burst out laughing,
bursting out, laughing, you
know, rather than being who?
I'm like the exact opposite of a,
uh, I was going to say a hemophiliac.
That's not what I'm trying to say.
What are those fucking people?
They're always nervous that they got
something, a hysterectomy. What does it,
I know it begins with an h.
This always happens to me.
It's what happens to my fucking
brain as I knew the word and I,
my brain panics and all I'm
left with is a letter, uh,
fucking hemophilia.
I can't get that word out of my head.
You know what?
I got to talk about something else.
Let's talk about the Jonas
brothers comedy show. Huh?
I think I speak for the group when
I say it's about time, you know,
because their music is fucking
hilarious. And, uh, I, I just,
you know, fucking cons. It's fucking
business. You know what I mean?
Rarely is is that, is that what I
should, that's not what I should've done.
I should've gotten this
business with fucking three,
three of my other brothers.
You know, I'll play the drums.
You get a Ukulele and then you do this
and then you'll get your own fucking
sketch show
sons of bitches.
Oh yeah, I'm better. I'm better
about the fucking Jonas brothers.
I want some goddamn stats here on dead
people. All right. I don't feel good.
So I want to read about dead people. All
the black death. Here we go. Here we go.
So black death was one of
the deadliest pandemics.
The fuck is a pandemic is
an epidemic and a pandemic.
A pandemic is an epidemic of infectious
disease that spreads through pop
populations across their large region.
For instance,
a continent or even worldwide.
Thank you. Wikipedia.
So what the fuck is an epidemic?
This is what happens and you just start
fucking search and everything and then
you figure out what the hell is.
An epidemic occurs when new cases of a
certain disease occur in a given human
population. During a given period,
isn't it the same fucking thing?
Is that not the same fucking
thing? A close enough. All right.
You guys want to hear
about the black death, Huh?
When you sit in there and your
cubicle at work? Well God damn it.
I'm going to read you some shit.
God knows you could do this yourself.
It's right there.
And Wikipedia.
The black death was according
to chronicles characterized
by boobos a swelling
and the lymph nodes. I don't even
know where the lymph nodes are.
I think there are they in your neck
a hypochondriac. Bam. I got it.
All right. See that's what I gotta do.
Just start talking about all this shit.
Then I didn't know where I yell out the
word and now I can't remember what I was
talking about. Oh, I know. I'm the
exact opposite of a hypochondriac.
Where a [inaudible]. No,
it doesn't make sense.
Hypochondriac cause nervous.
I had to keep my IUD. Apples.
Scientists and historians at the beginning
of the 20th century assumed that the
black death was an outbreak of the
same disease caused by the bacterium.
Who gives a fuck and spread by fleas with
the help of of animals like the black
rat.
However,
this view has recently been giving
me some stats for Christ's sake.
How many fucking people died?
What?
Wait, wait a minute. The origins of the
plagues, does that, did that to Deb.
Deeper depth at do.
The total number of deaths worldwide
is estimated at 75 million people,
approximately 25 to 50 million
of which occurred in Europe.
The black death is estimated to have
killed 30% to 60% of Europe's population.
Just stick about that people.
Six out of 10 automobiles that you'll see
in front of you tonight as you try and
drive home would not fucking be there.
And we already built the highways
to hold ya know a ton of fucking car.
You know what I'm saying?
You know it's America, man.
You want to fucking drive,
put the top down and I'm making Pontiac's
anymore. How fucking sad is that?
Let's think about some great Pontiac's.
That's where we're going to close out.
After we talked about the epidemic,
we talked about death.
Let's talk about how sad it is that
there's no more Pontiac's anymore.
There's just no more of
the Pontiac Trans Am, Huh?
Kinda drops off after that,
but you know,
yeah.
The Sun Bird,
the t 1000 you guys remember the Pontiac
t 1000 that was when you were really
fucked up when you bought
a bootleg Chevette.
That's when you really were saying that
you were an extra level of white trash.
Okay. You ate macaroni and
cheese five times a fucking week,
you know? You know, I can't imagine
what the Fuck I've even said today.
Did I,
was I riffing about Sharon?
A tray of macaroni cheese with
another man looking into his eyes.
Was that this podcast? Was that another
podcast? Was that at some point?
His show last night?
I don't know what,
but this has been the Monday morning
podcast for a April fucking 20 something.
I don't know what it is.
Oh know this is what we're into.
Garbage time. They still have their as
well. They were official site is still up.
What I would have Pontiacs or they
have the Bonneville. You know what?
They were a one trick pony.
Anybody drive a Pontiac?
I don't. Well, let's talk
about that next week. Okay.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
I'm be at Caroline's this week and then
I'm taking a break here for May and June.
Going to recharge my fucking batteries
and coming out, swinging in July.
I started the comedy works in Denver,
and then I go to a Eddie's
fist fuck in a fucking a Uma.
I'm just gonna make up shit now.
And then I'm going to be at a wallpaper.
Freddy's at the limelight.
Beautiful Theater.
We're raw.
Cirque de Solei performed just
reading the awful brochures here.
What is Cirque du Solei?
I really impressed with it.
The strength that those guys have. Not
so much on the costumes. All right,
you guys,
that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys all
have a tremendous week.
And I apologize if I was a little bit
grumpy this week, but, uh, you know,
I'm sorry. All right, that's on me.
I'm just gonna Pause. I'm sorry.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].